[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the program will
continue momentarily please remain
seated
ladies ladies and gentlemen
please take your seats
follow the model of the president of
Montenegro who is sitting
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it's my great honor
and pleasure to announce the president
of the French Republic
afternoon
[Applause]
it's wonderful to have him to have him
here
um
[Music]
the president has been a
regular guest of the Munich security
conference
he was here as advisor to president
alone he was here later on as minutes he
was here as president he was here in
2020 and he was here in 2021 virtually
and I'm very very happy to that you that
you came to
Munich and to tell us about your view of
things and I'm looking forward to our
discussion afterwards
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I cannot welcome each and every one of
you here in the room there's company
Representatives here Christoph huskin
head of the MSC esteemed friends I'm
very happy that we can get together here
today
in this spot where for the past 60 years
I believe it is now discussions have
been held that structure our world
discussions that have led to new
considerations in the transatlantic Bond
today we heard from president zielinski
and from federal Chancellor Schultz my
previous speakers and now I have to say
that speaking after them that it is very
apparent that the situation is very
serious
almost a year has passed since the
catastrophic war of aggression was
launched by Russia in Ukraine
and even though the time for conclusions
has not yet come I think we should look
ahead anyway or maybe take stock in a
certain way of course in my
deliberations today I would like to
focus on the war Russia is waging in
Ukraine but at the same time we must not
forget that there are other Wars that
are being waged in the Middle East in
the Caucasus region there is a war going
on against terrorisms
um questions of nuclear
issues are important as well but of
course today Ukraine is at the heart of
the matter after one year
taking stock leads to a very grave
result after this catastrophic conflict
and I think I want to highlight one
major point today this war as opposed to
everything we read today is not only War
for the Europeans it's a war that
concerns the world as a whole because
there is no justification at all for
this aggression I said this a few months
ago already when I spoke at the United
Nations
I said that this is a new imperialist
attitude that we see that is expressed
in this aggression towards a neighbor of
which you believe you must not respect
their entire territory
and that
there is a a law that needs to be a
right that needs to be claimed so the
assumption that new colonialism and new
imperialism were legitimate in this
world and secondly all taboos were
broken through this war of aggression
not only the charter of the United
Nations was violated no
it was violated by a member state of the
security Council
there has been systematic destruction of
critical infrastructure civilian
infrastructure crimes were committed
against the Ukrainian population against
civilians and nuclear threat is in the
room as well and the work done by Mr
groshi by the at the AAA is also hugely
important that I would like to value
that and appreciate that here and he's
also worked great with Iran we must not
underestimate that so this war has had
devastating consequences and Russia only
is responsible for this crisis a crisis
also a food supply for example despite
the measures that we have taken in
solidarity to the benefit of the
countries that require our protection
the most
those who believe that this is a
European matter well to those I say
there's only one aggressor and only one
party that was attacked this is clear
and we must not
um want a stable International
Organization uh
structure
without
stepping up for it and the second my
second consideration is this
it is the case that Russia's aggression
has basically been crowned by four clear
defeats the first defeat is the defeat
on the battlefield the basic assumption
for of Russia was that this war was
going to be quick that Ukraine cannot
resist and will fall within a few days
or maybe within a few weeks at most and
that the matter was settled the
incredible bravery of the Ukrainian
armed forces and the Ukrainian people of
the political leadership and Ukraine
especially and also of those friends who
are here today including the president
that we've seen on screen earlier
um
all that those that have shown this
bravery thwart at this plan the north
couldn't be taken and then we saw what
happened in her son you know we all
remember this and all this is a defeat
of the original military plan of Russia
the second defeat is the defeat of the
colonial mentality
so the point was to create confusion
you also create spheres of influence and
to act as though there was illegitimacy
for this war of aggression but that did
not work out even a year later this
hasn't worked out
so what this is about is to explain
that Russia is a power today that
creates imbalances and Injustice is not
only in Ukraine or in the caucuses or in
Africa with the Wagner group
we have seen this over the past few
years
we have seen how Russia proceeds and I
talked to President Putin about a year
ago and back then I believed him in a
way when he told me that the Wagner
group doesn't belong to him but now
these troops these this group is Now
official quote unquote and it's been a
direct military means or tool or even a
diplomatic tool that Russia is employing
it's a new mafiosi tool that Russia is
using everywhere
and it is used to create crimes and
commit crimes and create Injustice and
the third defeat is a defeat let's say a
defeat looking into the future
because the result is a consolidation of
Ukraine and its forces and the decision
by Sweden and Finland to join NATO and I
would like to tell the representatives
here how much we support them there is a
representatives of these countries we
want more International cooperation
there is a lot of mistrust towards
Russia
that has taken root and self-defense has
become more important but now in the
caucuses how can we assume that the
challenge there can be solved by Russia
by a state that is so neocolonial in its
Behavior I was reassured by the
president there that this is not the
path to go down and the fourth defeat
concerns me President Putin wanted to
give Russia what supposedly it wanted
which is a claim in the world so how
could Russia be happy with just being an
exporter of raw materials and not being
a nation that is important in the world
how can Russia just be a medium-sized
power
um that causes mistrust from all its
neighbors but that is now what the
situation is
two years ago I shared this exact view
here nobody can change the geography of
Russia Russia will always remain a part
of Europe geographically speaking and
nobody here in this room can
solve this dilemma
that there is no complete and long-term
peace in our continent as long as the
Russian matter has not been solved in a
reasonable fashion and without
a complacency but we have to continue in
this spirit Spirit and we have to take
this seriously
and this is what I have been underlining
time and again once the conflict has
start had started we must not be not you
show Unity
um act vigorously
end pursue dialogue as well wherever it
is possible but at the moment the hour
of dialogue hasn't come yet because
Russia chose War Russia chose to even
intensify this war Russia has decided to
attack civilian infrastructure and to
commit war crimes
for the short term the solution is
simple Russia must not and cannot win
this war and Russia's attack must fail
we must not allow
that resorting to force or violence
becomes normalized because that puts
into question stability in the world and
this is why together with our European
and American partners and many others
across the globe we have since the
beginning of the conflict created
outposts of security we have imposed
sanctions 10 packages worth of sanctions
that we have imposed on Russia's and we
have provided humanitarian and financial
and economic support to Ukraine to the
people of Ukraine and we also also
protected civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine we provided financial means and
let me thank the Secretary General at
this point for everything he's done and
every time France has pursued the path
of the greatest value added for Ukraine
for example by supporting air defense
and sending artillery and also training
Ukrainian Armed Forces at the same time
we also made sure that the
ukrainians can be protected but also
Romania dystonia for example we are
helping to strengthen them both the
defense of the Eastern flank of NATO but
also we're present in the Mediterranean
Sea
and we have joined Maritime groups there
too and that as a matter of fact since
the first day of days of the conflict
also there was always the question
whether this conflict would spread into
Romanian territory but over time time
and again we have worked towards
agreement basically and this is my
conviction we need to intensify our
support further to undertake more
efforts increase our effort in order to
help the Ukrainian people so that
Ukraine itself can launch a
counter-offensive
in order to then under credible
circumstances enter into negotiation
process chosen by Ukraine
we are ready
to intensify our efforts the next few
months and weeks will be decisive but at
the same time we also stand ready to
sustain a longer conflict I don't wish
for that nobody does of course but
together we have to remain credible
we have to remain credible in our
perseverance and this is what France
wants to highlight once again today
Unity
and determination are important to
provide Ukraine with a means to go back
to the negotiation table in an
acceptable fashion and to work on
long-term peace under conditions that
the ukrainians have decided upon and
identified
and in this context I would like to
call on all our European friends today
based on the convictions that I've just
shared with you my first call on you my
first appeal to you is this we need to
invest more in defense if we want peace
we need the means to achieve it France
in this regard is putting in its fair
share
so
November we passed the Strategic
compass and now we are working on a new
report for defense for the 24 to 2030
time frame we will provide a significant
number
as of Euros to support those efforts and
we have to do more as allies but
rearming ourselves also means that we
that we need to strengthen the European
Defense technological and Industrial
base and all the means that we have
developed recently
through the agenda of Versailles a year
ago need to be reinforced as well we
need to continue up on this path also
the Ukrainian Armed Forces need to be
enabled to continue on that path too
including with industrial support from
Europe and if Ukraine is supposed to
defend Europe it needs to be armed
accordingly it needs to be interoperable
with Europe and production capacities
need to be ramped up also across Europe
we need an investment program for
defense which is ambitious in all of
Europe so that we can make the best out
of the European Defense fund
we also do have to change maybe or think
about changing our Rhythm the War
Industry that we have been wanting to
strengthen in France since spring is
something where we need more progress we
need more standardization more
simplification at the European level
and my second appeal now
is this
we should
also consider the nuclear aspect of this
matter
[Music]
the there are non-verbalized questions
in this war and nuclear issues are one
of those nuclear weapons are
Russia's attack it took place in the
shadow of nuclear weapons and of course
we need to protect our allies
but at the same time this was all so a
wake-up call for us we need to ask
ourselves what role do nuclear weapons
play in the U and in NATO French
deterrence has a very decided spot
together with the UK together we are
responsible for the security of the
alliance and of course the Americans
play a key role in this regard and so I
wish that once again we
underline the nuclear features of our
Elias Alliance and that we consider once
again what that means and I would like
to repeat what I said in February called
the gear a dialogue with our partners on
nuclear's Friends Francis nuclear
deterrence
and what Europe derives from that is
crucial
and thirdly I would also like to call on
all of us to rethink our security
Doctrine
Europe should in all questions of Arms
Control have its place
I'm thinking of
medium range rockets and missiles
at one of the most recent native
meetings I underlined and you may recall
how important those weapons are the
United States has decided to not pursue
certain contracts or agreements or
treaties further and they concerned our
territory and we were not involved here
so basically we were a geopolitical
minority and that needs to end
it is a is about the security of Europe
that is at stake we need to think about
this we need to provide this type of
security and we need to guarantee it
together with our NATO Partners but also
as Europeans
this the INF treaty was discussed over
the past few years but we were not
invited to that and so there is no
treaty anymore like the INF
and we have to draw conclusions from
that
that would have an added value also for
the European Defense posture and would
strengthen our capabilities and defense
and reinvigorate them as well if we had
a tool like the INF treaty again that no
longer exists and that also ties in with
a more General topic that Federal
Chancellor Charles just brought up which
is air defense
here on the European continent and I
think it was right that President
Charles raised the issue of air defense
we Germans British French who want to
join in this effort should have a
conference on air defense in Europe we
should have a conference on that
including with industrial industry
Representatives inviting all those who
have solutions to offer here but also
from a strategic point of view we need
to consider this especially from a
strategic point of view
but at the same time deterrence and
affects
in the depth need to be considered this
is a central question for Europe Europe
needs to have its place in a future
security order my fourth appeal to you
is this
what mechanism could we have that could
prevent a cycle of aggression we need a
framework of transparency of
predictability in Europe with simple
principles like inviolability of borders
sovereignty of states the stabilizing
role of Europe that we should underline
so we need an architecture that is
credible
With Arms Control
and
finally we also need a framework that
prevents crises including long-term
crises on the continent
of course we will you we can use
existing structures like the osce and of
course Europe needs to be at the heart
of this I'm not thinking medically here
there is the EU yes but I think we need
to think the Europe bigger just as we've
done uh through the European political
community that has to play a special
role in this regard some Partners have
decided to leave the European Union but
they're a member of the European
political community
there are Partners in energy and
security and they share so many topics
with us and there are other countries
that want to join the European Union and
I hope they will do it today they're
quite far from it I think Norway
and the UK Moldova Ukraine you know this
is a European political community that
has the opportunity to prevent crises
like that and to create the architecture
I just outlined I would like to reassure
the president of Moldova of our support
once again
she's facing so many challenges and has
faced them and mastered them so we need
a space for cooperation on our continent
and NATO plays a very fundamental a key
role here and the last few months have
shown that all those who believed that
strength the strengthening of the
European pillar with the native was a
threat for NATO have understood now that
this basically strengthened our alliance
because of course this is just logical
to act this way and that with us with
this we have shown our determination to
reach strategic goals together and now
two more appeals to our European
Partners so my fifth appeal in addition
to the current conflict
we need to pull together in the future
when it comes to other conflicts that
are a threat to us already now
there is a risk that we're all facing
it's the risk of something that could
happen in the next weeks or months which
is more geopolitical shifts
we could potentially see new forms of
conflicts and new spaces like the
cyberspace or in the maritime sphere we
must not forget the vulnerability of our
democracies when it comes to
destabilization campaigns and
disinformation campaigns these spheres
will be exploited Maybe by Russia but
also maybe by other authoritarian powers
that in this context
Target our the destabilization of us so
we have to pool our capacities and our
investments and work together more
strongly in this area and now my last
appeal to all Europeans but also
everyone Beyond Europe also including
the United States
is this
let's prepare peace
for the short term we need to be strong
and determined and we need to be willing
to persevere
already now we need to prepare the
conditions for peace this is our
responsibility but this is not about
making bad compromises no we need a
credible piece
because a credible piece will be durable
but we will have to be prepared and
create the conditions for this piece and
that means that we need to work with
everyone let's say in Asia in the
Pacific in the Middle East in the Latin
America and Africa we need to be in
touch with our partners in those regions
who maybe do not fully share our views
that I just outlined and as I said
earlier in the beginning
we are often being accused of not
speaking the truth of not being quite
honest you know you spend so much money
on Ukraine we have faced Wars for years
and you never spent any money's money on
us you know we need to listen to these
concerns we need to listen to those
countries and to those regions and
together with those countries from those
regions we need to step up together and
exert pressure on Russia and create a
long-lasting peace and so that means
finally that we have to fight this
Narrative of double standards
I want to call on the G20 and the G7 to
stand by us to create a partnership
Partnership of the South and the North
in order to strengthen solidarity at the
international stage
to the benefit of health education the
fight of food scarcity and basically
creating more credibility for richer
countries
and countries that are currently
undergoing developments you know we need
to help those countries we need to show
them how we defend our principles
towards a durable and just peace in
Ukraine we want a more fair a more just
world we want a world that can tackle
the challenges of climate change in
those countries but also in other places
but responsibility is indispensable and
in all of that we must not forget what
the responses are to this new
geopolitical environment it also needs
to be a military military answer it must
be a response of resolve we need to
commit ourselves to a credible peace
to a strengthened and enhanced policy of
solidarity so that was a quite long
quite a long speech and I thank you for
your attention and thank you for letting
me share with you my convictions today
[Applause]
Mr President thank you very much for
your speech it had an advantage and a
disadvantage the advantage was it was
very comprehensive the disadvantage was
we don't have much time for questions
and I will not ask you a question but I
asked the public who didn't get to ask
questions to the German Chancellor so
you have a question for two two
questions
for the president I take the two
questions right after another and the
first one doesn't even need to raise his
hand Francois iceberg
can we have get a mic
short shorts
yeah just briefly
Mr President do you think that there